one of my all-time favorite development
sites is alligator IO so naturally I
think we should reverse engineer some of
its UI like all good development sites
it gives us the option to switch between
a light and dark mode and it even goes a
step further to give us solarized themes
as well in today's video you'll learn
how to build a feature like this from
scratch using CSS variables and a little
bit of JavaScript and it's actually a
lot easier than you might think along
the way you'll also learn a bunch of
other cool things like how to create
this triangle shape with CSS how to
create a drop-down menu without
JavaScript and we'll finish up the video
by giving our logo this rainbow white
color transition when we hover over it
if you're new here like and subscribe
and grab the source code for this
project on fire ship IO or github let's
start by taking a closer look at what
we're building today we have a navbar
that's based on flexbox when you click
on themes it opens a drop-down and I'll
show you a cool technique for keeping
this drop-down open using nothing but
CSS so no JavaScript is required for the
dropdown itself but when you click a
button inside it does use JavaScript to
change the CSS variables in the page to
update the theme you'll notice we have
an option for light and dark mode and
then an option to Solarize which gives
us a variation on top of these producing
a total of four different color schemes
and you'll also notice that after I
select a theme and then refresh the page
that theme is still applied we do that
by caching the users selection in the
browser's local storage on top of that
we'll look at how we can control shapes
and CSS and I'll throw in a variety of
different animation techniques as well
before we get started I just want to
remind you that we move pretty quickly
on this channel so feel free to pause
the video or slow down the playback
speed and if you want to jump to a
specific feature check out the
timestamps in the video description in
our project we have files for HTML CSS
and JavaScript all of which are
currently empty let's start things off
in the HTML to give our website some
structure hit exclamation mark tab to
create the initial HTML boilerplate from
there I'm using a custom font that I got
from Google and I set up the style sheet
by typing link : CSS and hitting tab and
then I referenced our JavaScript by
typing script : source and hitting tab
then we'll point that to app J s and
we'll make sure to use the defer
attribute so the script loads after our
HTML that autocomplete stuff was done
with Emmet which is built into vs code
if you're not already using
abbreviations like this to autocomplete
your HTML you definitely should be next
we'll go down to the body element and
give it a class of
you can think of this as our default
theme currently it doesn't do anything
but eventually we'll add CSS variables
to it that represent the light theme for
the site and then we'll write some
JavaScript to swap it out with different
classes then inside the body we have a
nav bar on the top that has a class of
nav bar and we have a header element
below it which is where our logo will go
and then we have the main content below
that which just contains some dummy text
our top navigation bar contains an
unordered list that'll be a flexbox
container and then inside that we'll
have a few list items which will be flex
items inside that container and
eventually we'll add a drop-down menu
here as well from there we'll throw out
the header which contains an image tag
and points to our logo PNG file
feel free to replace that image with
anything you want and below that we'll
use an h1 tag for the headline front-end
web development fired up and then we'll
use a paragraph element for a sub
headline below that and then inside the
main element we'll use my favorite
flavor of Epsom but if you don't like
this dummy text there are all kinds of
different if some generators out there
which you can see on lorem ipsum io now
if we open up our website in the browser
you can see that it's currently pretty
ugly let's go ahead and jump into the
CSS file to change that we can start by
quickly taking care of the boring things
like setting margin and padding to zero
on the body and then removing the
default list style for our navbar from
there I'll target the a element or the
links in the page and tell them to use
the current color by default HTML links
are an ugly blue color with an underline
instead of that we'll use current color
to tell our links to inherit the color
from the nearest parent this can be
really useful when combined with CSS
variables as we'll see later from there
we'll create our navbar we'll give it a
height of 70 pixels a width of 100% and
for right now we'll go ahead and set
their colors to static values but
eventually we'll come back and change
these two variables then we'll set up
the class that targets the unordered
list element in the navbar we'll make
that a Flex container align the items in
the center and then we'll space them
evenly across the horizontal axis and
then we'll set the height to 100% so it
fills the parent navbar the end result
is a basic navbar that looks like this
nothing too fancy but if you do want to
take things further I have a video for
that now our next objective is to design
the header and give it that cool
triangle shape at the bottom we'll start
by giving it some margin and padding and
aligning the text to the center that
gives us a standard rectangle that looks
something like this what we want to do
is trim out
of this rectangle so it makes that
triangle shape at the bottom the tool
used to do that in CSS is the clip path
property you can think of this as
putting a bunch of points around the
element that you can move around we can
use the polygon function to add as many
points as we want and then each argument
to this function represents a point
around that header element you'll notice
that each argument contains two
percentages this represents where the
point lives along the XY axis so in this
case zero zero would be the top left
corner and 100% 100% would be the bottom
right corner but when you use the clip
path property just open up your web site
in Firefox and use the clip path tool to
play around with it if you click the
icon it will actually set up the points
on the element and then you can drag
them around and it will automatically
update that property which you can then
use in your code if you want that takes
care of our header now we're going to
build a drop down menu using only CSS
first we'll go into our HTML and then
inside our navbar we'll add an
additional list item but this one has a
has drop-down clasp on it inside that
list item we'll add a link and then an
additional unordered list which
represents the drop down that drop down
we'll have a few drop down items inside
it then each individual drop down item
has its own link and for each of those
links will provide an ID that represents
the theme that we want to switch to so
in this case an ID of light dark and
solar will need the IDS to grab these
links when we get to the JavaScript in a
few minutes our drop down menu has a
position of absolute and a fixed width
of 500 pixels and we'll set the opacity
to 0 by default making it invisible
until it's actually focused we also need
to set the z-index
greater than its parent element which in
this case will be 2 that will make it
appear on top of the main nav bar that
it sits inside of we'll give it a
background and a border and then we'll
round out the bottom two corners by
targeting them individually
now the actual buttons in the drop-down
are aligned horizontally so we'll set
the display to flex align the items in
the center then maximize the space
around the items inside that row to
preview it I'm going to temporarily set
the opacity to 1 and now you can see
underneath this theme link we have this
drop down menu we can make things look a
little nicer by adding a box shadow and
then I'll also move the item a little
bit to the left so it's more centered
around the parent theme link and we can
do that by translating along the x-axis
and that looks a lot better but how do
we open and close this drop down we need
to determine when something inside the
drop down is focused
and then we'll change the opacity from
zero to one a transition on the parent
element will make the opacity fade in
and out when it loses focus now remember
in the HTML on that list item we gave it
a class of has dropped down well use the
pseudo selector focus within to detect
when a link inside that drop-down has
been focused when that's the case we'll
set the opacity of the drop down to 1
now when we go and click on the theme
link it creates focus on that link which
will cause the drop down to fade in
if we click outside of it it loses focus
and fades out and that's how you build a
clickable drop-down menu using nothing
but CSS what I'm doing next is just
polishing some of the drop-down items
I'll have each link take up all of the
available space and then I want to
display a circle next to each link with
the corresponding color for that theme
there's a few different ways to create
circles with CSS but one way is to
target the before pseudo element this
allows you to add an element before the
link itself which in our case will just
be an empty string but we'll give that
empty string a border of two pixels and
a border radius of 50% with an equal
width and height which will give us a
perfect circle then we'll refine the
alignment and margins and the end result
should look like this and so now that
our main UI is done the question becomes
how do we dynamically change the color
theme using CSS and JavaScript well the
first thing we should do is outline our
themes will target the root element and
then we'll define classes for light dark
and solar the root element is where I
like to define variables for static
values that don't change things like
colors breakpoints and so on for this
demo I have seven gray colors that are
ordered from lightest to darkest and
then we'll throw in blue purple and
yellow as well that gives us our color
scheme but in real life you'll likely
have many more colors than this and a
cool tool that you might want to check
out to generate colors automatically is
colors Co now that we have the color
scheme we can use them to define
variables that represent different
elements of the UI like our base
background will be gray zero so we're
creating a variable that's based on
another variable and by the way if
you've never heard of CSS variables
before in your life make sure to check
out 100 seconds of CSS variables we can
also use our variables to build up more
complex values like a linear gradient so
our nav background will be a linear
gradient that goes from left to right
using the variable gray one and the
variable grade three
and then we'll continue doing this for
other variables that we plan to use on
the UI like the text and the border
color for example now when it comes time
to create a different theme like our
dark theme we can simply use the same
variable names but give them different
values our dark theme will use the
background of grey v instead of gray
zero but the text will use grey zero to
give contrast against that background so
the takeaway here is that the brand
colors always stay the same but the way
they're used changes between the
different themes but you don't
necessarily have to do things that way
for example in our solar theme will
override the grey colors directly to
give them a more yellow green shade this
allows us to use our existing
enlightened dark themes but override the
base colors to make them appear
different you just need to make sure to
give your colors the same contrast ratio
if we go back to our website you can see
it looks exactly the same as before why
is that well we haven't actually used
our variables yet the next step is to go
into our Styles and use the variables
that we defined in our themes basically
anything that had a static color before
now has a variable value another cool
trick is that you can animate the change
between themes by setting a transition
on the background and color properties
and I'll make the background change a
little bit faster than the text color to
give it sort of a cool offset effect now
after changing all the values in your
Styles you should be able to go to the
body and change the light class to dark
and you should see the colors update
automatically and if you include the
solar class it should override the
grayscale colors and now we're at the
point where it's time to implement some
JavaScript to allow the user to change
the theme dynamically in our JavaScript
code we first need to grab all of the
elements from the Dom so we'll do that
for each one based on the ID that we
said in the HTML and we'll also make a
reference to the body element then we
need to listen to the click event on
each one of these buttons and run a
callback function on each click
switching between light and dark mode is
pretty straightforward we just need to
replace the light theme with the dark
theme one way to do that is to look at
the class list on the body remove the
light theme and then add the dark theme
that'll work perfectly fine but we could
do this with one line of code using
class list replace and replace the light
theme with the dark theme and that's the
better way to go in this case because
there are mutually exclusive themes and
we can do the same thing for our light
button but replace the darkness with
light and now if we go down to the drop
down menu you should be able to switch
between light and dark mode now the
solar theme works a little bit different
because instead of being mutually
exclusive it's a
applied on top of either light or dark
mode will use a conditional statement to
see if the body element already contains
the solar class and if so we'll remove
it and another cool thing you can do is
you can actually change the variables
directly by modifying the CSS text in
your JavaScript it's not essential for
this demo but sometimes you might want
to calculate colors directly in your
JavaScript in which case you could
modify the CSS text directly and as an
added touch we'll change the inner text
of the solarized button based on its
state then we'll apply the exact
opposite logic on the other side of our
conditional statement if it doesn't
contain the solar class then we'll go
ahead and add it so now we can switch
between all our themes but if the user
refreshes the page they're going to lose
whatever theme they selected luckily we
can easily cache their selection in the
browser using local storage which is a
simple key value store that's built into
the browser you can access it by simply
calling local storage in your script and
the first thing we'll want to do when
our script runs is get the users
existing theme and then also determine
if they are using the solar theme or not
if there is an existing theme saved and
we'll go ahead and add that theme to the
body of the document and if local
storage also has a value for the solar
theme then we'll go ahead and add the
solar theme to the body as well and this
code will run anytime the page is
refreshed or any time the user visits
the website in a different window or
browser to app and now the question
becomes how do we save these values to
local storage we can do that by coin set
item where the first argument is the key
or theme in this case and the second
argument is the value or dark and then
apply that same operation to our light
theme when it comes to the solar theme
we can actually just remove the is solar
property because when the user is not
using solar we don't need that property
at all and when they are using it we'll
just set the property to true now when
we go to the web page and select a theme
and then refresh the page it should
still apply that theme and you can
actually go into the browser console
type in local storage and it will show
you the key value pairs that are saved
there and if you type in local storage
clear it will erase those values we've
already done a lot here but I did
promise you one more thing and that's
this rainbow animation when I hover over
the logo it's really easy to do and can
work on any type of image back in our
CSS we'll go ahead and set up a
keyframes animation called color rotate
it will animate from a filter property a
cue rotate of zero degrees which is
normal and then we'll cycle through
every color in the color wheel by
setting the hue rotate to 360 degrees
and now we just need to apply this
animation to our logo
when we hover over it we'll set the
animation property to our color rotate
keyframes and a duration of one second
we'll have it apply the animation in an
infinite loop and then we'll set the
animation direction to rotate which will
rotate the color wheel from clockwise to
counterclockwise and now our logo has
this cool rainbow effect when we hover
over it I'm gonna go ahead and wrap
things up there if this video helped you
please like and subscribe and let me
know what project you'd like to see next
in the comments thanks for watching and
I will see you in the next one
[Music]